kurz erklärung was minecraft halten
überhaupt ist minecraft halten ist ein
pvp projekt wo ich mit meinem bruder sc
zog in einem team im team hat drei team
herzen und sobald diese herzen wechseln
kann halt keiner bei respawn vom team
plus ist können neue herzen gewonnen
werden falls einmal rausgeflogen ist in
dem man ein team als einzelpersonen
ausschaltet dazu gibt es noch einige
mods die das ein bisschen spannender
machen abwechslungsreicher und insgesamt
ein sehr kunstprojekt ich bin sehr
gespannt und jetzt viel spaß sollte und
herzlich willkommen zur ersten folge von
minecraft 1032 los wieder in die mitte
jetzt auch nehmen die kiste und du die
andere nach hinten gab wo wir herkommen
laufen ins haus da macht es erstmal
schwerter was machst du
schwerte ich wollte nur ins haus liegen
sagt vielleicht anders wahr was sofort
ich habe den mythos ist ob sie fanden
als buchmacher stammbuch ich den stoff
bisschen aufgeregt hautnah wieder
zerstört wieder träume ich sehe nichts
aber bei mir läuft es nicht so
übertrieben flüssig muss ich selber mir
auch nicht bei mir auch nicht erstens
namen suchen kommt deine talente rechts
da werden mittags geburek dass das
höffner ok auch haubner und überhaupt
nochmal ich kann ihn nicht pusten müssen
als lag ein bisschen ok haubner ist
schonmal separiert ja es liegt auf jeden
fall
ich habe keine hitze ich kann ja auch
nicht treffen
bvb nina und tobias haben wir ab oder
her ich kann haupt nämlich hätten was
ist das ich kann dir nicht hinten den
jungen was ist das denn
what the [ __ ] was los ich kann den typen
nicht hinten was ist das für eine
scheiße kommt bekommst du sonst ja das
ist doch eine scheiß witz alter hätte
ich so kann ich den typen nicht hätten
was für eine scheiße das gibt's doch
nicht komisch water fakt alter ok kommen
auf hat mir folgt mir alles gut
wir wissen aber schon mal was für ein
scheiß man verstehe ich auch nicht du
konntest du auch nicht hätten ich konnte
ihn nicht hätten ich war so nah dran
leute so startet man nicht hätten
könnten sterben
das war dann komplett abschalten ihrem
blog da drüben sind ist schon krass
erst recht aber immerhin würde ich
diesmal nicht von tobi getötet
hey immerhin wurde diesmal nicht glaubt
von den baggies getötet habermann ich
konnte einfach nicht hätten konsument
darf mal regen aussteller mit ob die
feine sicher oder backups ob man den
ausständen den regen das wissen machen
doppelter und fachmedien mit auf die
ferne ausstellen muss aber aufpassen
nicht nicht weit weg ich hab dich jetzt
kurz aus dem blick verloren warum ist da
vorne us zu essen und sohn jett ein brot
nicht dass ihr aufwies dafür bekommt er
einen polizeiwagen fleisch stehen ich
habe kein essen kein schwert wilhelm
werden jetzt versteigert immer stein und
essen oder hast du kannst stein für
stein
vielleicht schaffe ich in der ersten
folge raus zufrieden kann ich ein
schwert machen
ich will mir aber allerdings schwer
was ist das moor wo doch sieht mehr im
chat das tier wird des mordes aber
kommen die hätte ohne diesen gegner
macht sich faxen mit diesem komischen
sperrt macht macht man's macht bitte
keine faxen darum sind zwar gegner
lassen sie holen ja da hast du hast du
jetzt ein stein geworfen
sodann verdammt oder egal egal wir sind
sehr effizient freunde ist eine woche
und ich kann locker nicht mehr zu den
sprinten
ja okay dann bleibt ja bei dir die
vorgänge vor sollte müssen geschützt
vorne sind die freunde also ich
regeneriere hat nur mehr bin ich hier
oben glaube sie sind links gegangen
wir sind links links nein ich meine die
wände hochgegangen
kannst du noch rote kräften bestimmt
auch nicht
ich habe auch nur noch ein beat hast du
vielleicht noch einzeln an einer von
zehn sprüngen ein weizen habe ich noch 1
3 verloren
wir bleiben ganz dicht zusammen weil wir
haben könne nicht mehr sprinten also der
familie nicht das jetzt hier holen uns
an diese wegkommt und sind vorne sind
tiere auf jeden fall direkt hinter
freund denn wir sind von links was ist
denn das bei solchen bauten sachen drin
ja es gibt übrigens apple baut ich hätte
es mal länger als ein jahr oder aber
hast du offen
ich werde okay sind die rein gegangen
oder niemals waren da hinten echt
niemals diesen dahinter aber die kriegen
wir nicht oder ist schwierig aber da ich
würde dir auch gerne angreifen
ja da ist ganz viel von diesem special
norden zieht und zieht damit aus kann
man sich täuschen resistance rüstung
machen
ok jetzt nicht mal unter schlägt auf
jeden fall muss das eisen noch mehr
citrin auskommen auch schwerter machen
echt und die die haben 25.000 chance
also es gibt richtig geil arbeit oder
sogar ein paar mal davon ab was du
kriegst du mal kurz auf den ausgang was
allerdings haben wir nicht wissen ob ihr
projekt mit über 40 gegnern richtig
großen wenig hat er schon gesehen die
buddys ak angreifbare hacks war dies
die ich habe nichts gehört nichts gehört
wurde wegen der aber die sache ist ist
das projekt es gibt hier im wesentlichen
drei erweiterung und zwar eine rüstung
die kraft konnte man sich ausländer
materialien die gibt einem feuer
resistenz das erschwert kann verbrennen
in der 50 prozentigen chance das kann
man kräfte man sich aus den materialien
heißt wir sollten bald eigentlich dazu
gibt es dann die citrix rüstung heißt es
glaube ich dass dieser gelbe stoff wie
die zitrone die rüstung gibt resistenz
gegen also mit der rüstung kann man auch
ein feuer in lara schwimmen sogar so
groß ist die feier resistenz wenn die
vollständig ist und die citrix ist und
gibt vollständigkeit resistenz gegengift
zum beispiel und das schwert hat eine 25
prozentige vergiftungs recht so wir
brauchen unbedingt noch
ein iron mindestens oder wollte ich
eigentlich abgebaut haben trotzdem ein
bisschen lag damit mit diesem material
geben können das wäre schon sinnvoll
wenn wir die diesmal noch kassel so
wenig abgebaut oder darum seine buskohl
was habe ich zufällig selbst ganz
zufällig in bester qualität hervor dem
baby hatte überhaupt keine lex habe ich
sie dreimal gerettet ist dieses riesen
österreich ohne mittelalter ein bisschen
ärgerlich anfang
es werden aber keine leben wegen lecks
zurückerstattet und das lebens system
ist so jedes thema drei leben solange
das team mehr als nur leben hat man
respawn dem jetzt noch 1 man verliert
für jeden tod ein leben für jeden kriegt
man ein halbes zurück und wir wollen so
ein bisschen draufgänger machen ihm ein
beifahrer sind wie immer oder ist
eigentlich jeder sehr defensiv und hier
finden ist es eine gute gelegenheit mal
was anderes auszuprobieren und bislang
immer mal wissen was das hier drunter
ist
grüne wollen
es ist ja nicht ist eine falle ist es
gibt auch fallen auf der map würde ich
mal sagen ziemlich sicher gibt es eher
verhalten leute job eine kohle aus der
wand wir haben aber man muss auch sagen
dass hier eine menge arbeit hinter
steckt eine menge arbeit reingesteckt
ist sollte man jetzt auch gar keinen
fall madig reden also das schon eine
gute sache die sie auf die beine
gestellt haben jetzt noch vielleicht
vergessen jubel world vorzuladen
wir brauchen definitiv noch ein ding
rein weil das wäre echt schade wenn wir
die dias und so weiter nicht abbauen
diese folge ist keine einmal ein
weiteres allem fehlt noch das gibt es
nicht leider ja nicht deckt also mein
leben ist vorbei und man mich nicht so
rolleyes irgendwie kommt also es ist ein
bisschen strange schritt von der
flüssigkeit aber freunde wir werden die
nächste folge einfach wenn wir jetzt die
sachen kriegen das aber nicht vor
gericht als brown gehen weil die
aufnahmezeit beträgt pro folge wir
nehmen uns schon zwölf minuten auf das
feld geschickt werden oder wie er
deshalb sollten wir wirklich wirklich
schnell
ok kriegst du noch kohle irgendwo zweite
mal hier unten ist ihr und cleanskin
store herunter
mal gucken ob du noch irgendwo
mitbekommen was hat es damit auf sich
ich bleibe hier oben erstmal ich habe
hier oben aber irgendwas ist oder wie
man das machen ja vorher nicht sehr über
dieses grüne zeugs das was ganz gut ist
glaub ich dieses zieht ja sehr gut das
ist sehr gut dann können wir nicht
machen
wir müssen die aktionäre aber dafür
fehlen uns nur noch ein einziges eilen
ich würde auch einen machte dass ich war
oder fall opel gt besser weggelassen
sich gut auf das ist der wahnsinn das
ist der wahre boss
jetzt steht uns nicht bewegen so außer
das wird vielleicht ein verfluchtes
tracks fuhren einen brocken davon zu
sagen oder mit softbox ich sage ich kann
nicht erkennen
ihr kennt vielleicht besser ein video wo
hat muss mir auch fackeln machen weil
die meisten glaube ich zumindest zu
einem zeitpunkt also in der konten
geschrieben kein gar keiner kann man die
glaswand augen abbauen
die glotze in der höhle dann kann man
die abreise namen rufen hier ne das habe
ich selbst auch noch 1 im 1 genau dann
bricht es schon mal man hier ist nur
queenston ist es der ernst der sache an
den opern gar nicht in den ofen rein da
ist sogar so ein ofen also vielfach
structure die werden auf jeden fall mehr
kunden aber ich komme einfach gerade
nicht in den ofen rhein viel besser nur
von einer anderen seite dran hörst du
mich max ich kann gar nicht außen vor
wie time aus ich glaub des servers
gecrasht warum fängt am mittag aber muss
ich an zu spielen
ich glaube der service leidet musiker zu
spielen
ich bin gerade vom von server unter
geflogen
fakt ist dass ich bin auf dem server
gefunden
leute meine in meiner bude spuckt
einfach wie flash oder wartest der kick
ohne message einfach das könnte sein
eine aufnahme oder 15 52 uhr das passt
wie heute dann war es soweit von der
ersten folge taten
wir haben vor steuer erst mal nach ob du
geister im haus lassen los dass man ja
man ist einfach musik spielt macht heute
team es ist für euch am start
erste folge die basis legen macht's gut
tschüss